nine Americans now have died in the u.s.
from the corona virus that's according
to health officials in the state of
Washington this is New York State
confirms a second case with me now the
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio and
Sarah nice to see you on the Super
Tuesday a lot to talk about
a lot to get to how you doing feeling
good tell me about the two cases in New
York what do we know about that well we
have one who is a health care worker
came back from Iran she seems pretty
healthy overall in her 30s we think
she'll do okay we got another case it's
a little more worrisome bill older
gentleman had some pre-existing
respiratory conditions he's now
hospitalized in New York City we're
concerned about him the woman who came
back from Iran apparently she flew back
here to New York she was in a private
car and she checked herself in the
hospital and then she went home correct
no I understand she went home when she
had symptoms in later days she reached
out to the hospital went there got
tested etc came back home self-isolation
so she's I mean she's a professional
how is it that we see these Americans
come off his cruise ship in Japan they
go straight to Nebraska because they
have a fever
why is she able to take care of herself
at home why is that okay because look
for someone who is reasonably healthy
like this you're gonna want them to be
in a home setting again here's the thing
about coronavirus according to our
health care professionals if for most
people it's gonna manifest like a cold
or the common flu that's the thing to
understand the vast majority of cases
are not this scary unknown disease they
actually play out like something we all
know pretty well so if someone's
reasonably healthy they can be at home
we want to keep them away from everyone
else just going in a car somewhere is
not enough from what we are just trying
to get the distinction between why you
sent somebody to a medical facility in
Nebraska and why you allow someone to go
home in a city of eight million people I
think each locale may have its own
standards I mean obviously our public
health capacity is pretty renowned
around the country but I also think it
depends on the condition of the
individual if someone we think is stable
it's a different reality than if someone
might not be you said yesterday same-day
service in New York yes
test kits I know adequate in numbers are
you prepared yes and and the federal
government look they did some things
right but one thing they really missed
the ball I was getting that testing
capacity as local as possible we finally
have it it's going to make a world
difference same-day service and we're
going to be building the capacity to
what's the plan if you get an outbreak
in a city of eight million what do we do
look we have to try step by step to stay
ahead of it today we have two confirmed
cases out of eight point six million
people you know I think we have time to
prepare but it's crucial that now we can
test and know what's going on let's talk
about Super Tuesday you're a supporter
Bernie Sanders I am what happens tonight
I feel very good I'll tell you look
early voting alone I think Bernie's done
an amazing job with his campaign of
reaching those early voters getting them
out I think the turnout apparatus is
being underestimated build and you saw
it in Nevada
Bernie's ground game is far beyond any
other candidates a second the enthusiasm
levels we see this in all the polling
Bernie voters really cared they're gonna
show up today the ones that haven't
voted already I think he's in a very
strong position to end the night or when
the voting is finally done whenever that
is nowadays with a clear delegate lead
and to be in the driver's seat and it's
going to be Bernie versus Joe Biden
which I think it will be that contrast
is extraordinary for folks who want the
status quo Joe Biden is a great choice
for folks who want to change this
country it's going to be Bernie Sanders
and I think that includes a lot of your
viewers I there's a lot of working
people in this country a lot of
middle-class people who don't like the
status quo and they want an outsider
they can believe in that's that's a
perfect setup for this if you could
enact all the policies that you and
Bernie Sanders support right
what's America look like America looks
like a more fair place for working
people and look it's a free enterprise
system it's a system where people can
take plenty initiative and have plenty
of rights but we're finally you know
that you can get health care that you're
not going to be devastated by a medical
bill that you know your government is
actually trying to stop global warming
before it destroys the lives of our
children and grandchildren I think at
what cost I think I'm looking at
Medicare for all the estimates are
between 14 and 36 trillion dollars right
but 14 at the low end green New Deal
starts at 10 trillion dollars problem is
the problem is I take us back to a point
Bernie made a very powerful analogy he
made in one of the debates at the
beginning of world war two we had
effectively no military we weren't ready
in this country in the course of just
two or three years produced the greatest
military in the world
drove back the Nazis and the Japanese
this country when focus can do amazing
things we have to stop global warming
and we have to get health care to give
me a state other than Vermont where
Bernie Sanders beats Donald Trump oh my
god that polling is consistent including
some of your own polling by this network
here in the majority here's an example
then you Florida is gonna be hotly
contested yet again just in the last
week or so this is what we heard from
Bernie Sanders just watching it's unfair
to simply say everything is bad you know
when Fidel Castro came into office you
know what he did he had a massive
literacy program you know what I think
teaching people to read and write is a
good thing that Cuba made progress on
education yes I think really really and
when dictatorships whether it is the
Chinese or the Cubans do something good
you acknowledge that you've heard all
this concert how does that win in
Florida a bill I don't think that's what
people are caring about when they cast a
vote they care about their jobs their
families the health care their families
need look we are not going to replay the
Cold War in the 2020 election 2020
election is going to be about people's
standard of living about whether the
next generation can do better than they
have done which most Americans don't
believe right now and whether we're
going to survive on this earth here's
the we can't afford not to make these
investments but to your point about win
ability the vast majority of national
polls show Bernie Sanders beating Donald
Trump I've seen that including in
Wisconsin including in Michigan
including Pennsylvania think about
working-class folks who Bernie can
appeal to in a way bluntly no other
Democrat can I think you can pull back
some of those votes that Donald Trump
let's see how it goes tonight what is it
between you and Mike Bloomberg I think
what Mike Bloomberg did in this city is
only beginning to be recognized and stop
and frisk alone or to create a
tremendous division between our police
in our community I think because of his
wealth he got away with a lot and now
there's a reckon you hold that against
him of course I don't hold against the
fact that someone worked hard reading
money listen you can make money that's
great but if you use your money to mask
a truth that bothers me he did a lot of
harm here in
New York City a lot of people wouldn't
call them out because they were scared
of his wealth actually it's pretty
amazing that debate show democracy is
alive and well doesn't matter he's one
of the richest guys in the world that
debate showed the truth they sent me a
long list of allegations and ethics
abuses that they would hold against you
as as mayor I'm shocked what you say
doctor first of all they're wrong my
administration has been there for
working people from the beginning and we
are perfectly clean and consistent to
what we do but Mike Bloomberg divided
politically and set us back in a lot of
ways and now the truth is finally is is
it is it personal it's because he did
not endorse you during your primary nor
yours again oh no we disagreed entire I
would never expect him to I never would
expect him to it's personal in the sense
that we don't have personal chemistry
that's a true statement but it's much
more about beliefs I don't know how a
Democrat with all the respect have a
Democrat goes and joins the Republican
Party for expediency and then supports W
or W Bush for president 2004 and then
comes around 2020 he says I want to be
the DA said even against his will Bernie
Sanders the denominator he'd support him
and I admire it would you support Mike
bloom yes you would of course of course
because even though I disagree with him
I can tell you the things I agree them
on I think he's very strong for example
on climate and public health and he
unquestionably to me would be a better
president Donald Trump last point if
it's not decided by tomorrow sometime
soon as Milwaukee going to be a mess in
July I think what will happen is it
won't be tomorrow but I do think the
momentum is with Bernie when you look at
the states up ahead he's gonna do great
here in New York I think he's gonna
great in Pennsylvania Bernie's gonna win
this by the will of the voters I don't
see a contested convention I see a
Bernie Sanders victory through the vote
him winning Pennsylvania yeah and
obviously Joe Biden absolutely because
of the passion that he generates working
people young people we're seeing more
and more multi-generational multiracial
coalition look Bernie Sanders gets
people to feel something because he's
real they can tell he's actually cares
about working people it sounds like some
that America was introduced to in 2016
would you agree and I will tell you
something outsider Donald Trump wins
outsider Barack Obama wins outsider
Ronald Reagan wins when are the pundits
gonna get the message being an outsider
is a good thing
America I appreciate you being here I
hope you come back and I hope more
people like you come back because we can
have a fair exchange of ideas by the way
we all should be talked about taking it
up here we all should be talking to each
other Thank You mr. mayor
guess what we're all Americans I've got
more questions I hope you come back
thank you don't absence to do